hey guys been a minute since we picked
up a camera and made a video so today is
officially two weeks in the new home we
haven't recorded anything because as you
know moving is crazy hectic so I'm sorry
we have completely forgotten to pick up
a camera and document this whole process
but as of right now the coronavirus
stuff is gone crazy all the shelves are
gone like empty is what I hear from
social media waking up this morning I
have really started getting scared
because of the fact that we have just
moved into the new house we have been
putting off grocery shopping and also
tomorrow we're supposed to be getting
our brand new fridge to come in and
that's the reason why we haven't gone
shopping at all so I'm gonna show you
guys in a bit our refrigerator and our
pantry right now which is practically
empty and because of that reason that's
mainly the only reason why but I am I'm
getting scared there's there's a there's
a rumor going around that the
government's gonna pretty much have
everyone self quarantine for for a few
weeks and I don't know how true that is
but that is scaring the crap out of me
because I'm like we have we're not ready
we're not prepared we have no food
however you missed a home for possibly a
month luckily I just bought new water
filters so we're good on water and I
just locked toilet paper so we're good
on toilet paper but I woke up this
morning really scared but let me
distract myself a little bit and just
show you guys the the house right now
how it is the state within two weeks of
us living here so it's kind of funny
because our bedroom is kind of setup
similarly to the old place except back
there we don't have the sliding doors to
a balcony the plan is to move that here
and move this here once this is gone but
that's gonna take some time we have a
new dresser that we haven't built yet I
got this new hamper which I was waiting
for this to come in before I did the
first load of laundry because right over
that door is open is the laundry room
and you guys know how excited I have
been to do the first load of laundry
here so I have been waiting for that
hamper so I could document the very
first laundry load that we do in the new
place but look how cute it is I got it
at Urban Outfitters in case you guys are
wondering this is a regular hamper that
we already usually use so I got these
really cute bath rugs also from Urban
Outfitters really really cute I'm
planning on setting up this whole
bathroom thing to be really cute
eventually in terms of the blinds you
see right now we have all of the windows
covered up with paper but the blinds
lady came in a couple of days ago I
decided to go with the zebra blinds so
like could still come in throughout the
day and we still have privacy and then
you can close it at night and have
complete privacy so I thought that was
the best option for our home here's a
closet we are gonna completely redo this
closet I've been thinking about getting
this closet system for my keeo where
it's like from the ceiling all the way
to the floor and in like different
levels and that is an eventual project I
do want to tackles but as of now I just
ordered the drawers so we can be using
the the dresser drawers to put our stuff
away in the meantime but eventually this
closet is gonna look completely
different hopefully if I ever get around
to it we have our washer and dryer and
yeah look at this the doors don't hit
Ted I'm so excited for this load of
laundry maybe doing today here is the
office slash spare room that we have
this is gonna take a while to do but
eventually I'm trying to put this like
really pretty green futon that we have
or blue I think blue futon that we have
in Casey's office at the JK office we're
moving it here maybe a little coffee
table thing here and I don't know we'll
play with it but this is what it looks
like as of right now I would show you
Isaac's room but he's not home to give
me permission to show you so I feel
weird invading his private
like that so I'm not going to show you
his room but as of right now his bed is
on the floor because we're trying to
sell his old loft bed and I haven't
ordered his new bedroom set yet
look we ordered this really cute cactus
scratching post but he has no idea that
he can scratch this up because both him
and Maya haven't touched this at all but
look how freaking cute it is I love it
it's like decorative it's really pretty
I like it so are you ever gonna play
with that probably once we get rid of
this guy oh yeah by the way here is our
current state of the downstairs so we're
trying to sell that we're trying to sell
those couches we're trying to get rid of
this I need to mount the TV up to the
wall I already have all the things I
just got to mount it this is this is
what we got going on oh yeah and then
like we ended up hanging some plants
those are not gonna stay there we were
just testing out to see which plant
would look the best so we can just cover
all of it up here with some greenery oh
I bought this this liner which I'll show
you in the pantry in a second how it
came out and then we started so we
decided we're gonna be doing some gold
accent stuff so I ended up changing out
the crocks to be like gold crock and
then we bought some some mini cutting
boards and yeah so the plan is to have
gold accents because there's some gold
on this backsplash so we that's the
reason why we're kind of going with gold
but then also we're playing with silver
because of the appliances yeah we'll see
how it all comes out once we do this
stuff because I recently ordered our
dining table which it's this really cool
table that extends and the reason why I
bought it is because I saw it in an
Instagram ad the fact that it extends
from like two people to 12 people I'm
like that's perfect
this is a little bill I'm like that's
perfect cuz then the chen clan comes
over when we have a party we could
extend it and just fit a whole bunch of
people in the dining table and then the
coffee table that we decided to buy
it matches the dining-table because
that's where the extra panels go
so you distracting me boy you [ __ ]
kitty he's so cute but yeah that's what
is eventually gonna be here I really
want a lot of color the vibe I'm trying
to go for it is like bohemian / bold /
modern a little bit and maybe a little
bit like the dashes of like mid-century
because remember in a previous vlog I
said that I'm I'm really worried about
hopping on trends because eventually
it's gonna look really dated and the
mid-century trend I can already clearly
see like oh my gosh that's so early 2010
2020s but it's okay whatever I'm kind of
over it now and I just want a place that
I'm gonna like and that KC's gonna enjoy
because it's just gonna look stylish and
no matter what eventually trends come
and go it's gonna be dated but it's fine
at least we can enjoy it in the meantime
so that's the vibe that I'm trying to go
for down here when I'm interior
designing and then I try to ask KC for
his input he's like honestly I'm not
good at this stuff and I trust you so
just go for it okay but now that we're
in the kitchen though I'm gonna show you
our current states of our refrigerator
don't judge us it's really really dirty
we're gonna clean it but this is all we
got this is all we have we have alcohol
the mote milk some old the what are
these called like 100 year old eggs that
case he calls them leftover rice
compares tofu and this is it we have hot
sauces ginger and cilantro this is all
we got oh and some garlic this is all we
have so yeah guys I'm a little more
worried I and all this is Casey's to
pick them for his eczema then making
sure that he doesn't run out so stocking
up and then here is the pantry this is
what the pantry looks like it's not a
lot we I don't think we can survive a
whole month even not even a week with
like the stuff we have here it's
little food we have some canned foods
like some tuna beans jeopardy but yeah
this is the reason why I'm kind of
panicking
we don't have will have very much food
oh and this is what the lining looks
like it's cute right I like it that's
the project that I'm gonna be working on
today I'm gonna finish lining the pantry
so we could fit in whatever we managed
to get from the groceries or from the
grocery store so we can stock this all
up and feel a little safer oh let me
show you the garage so this is our
garage my car is parked inside because I
have to charge but other than that this
is the mess that we have so about 90% of
everything in here are things that we're
trying to sell we're just trying to get
rid of or donate just any sort of way
that we can just get it out of our hair
Isaac's black couch his lava bed the TV
stand in his room we have the extra
dining chairs here oh yeah we have our
old coffee tables there's a lot of stuff
things like the bicycles and our camping
things these are things that we're
obviously trying to keep but yeah we
don't really have a lot of storage space
in this house it's nothing compared to
what we had in the old place cuz you
know those those two empty places in the
garage like storage spaces that was
really helpful we were able to fit a lot
of stuff there so the point where we had
large amounts of cardboard trash for the
last four years that were just chillin
there cuz that's how much space we had
for storage but now we don't have very
much storage because KC eventually is
gonna be parking here once we get the
SUV that he's been dying to get to
Telluride that's gonna eat up a lot of
storage space too that's the home right
now two weeks living here and I will see
you when Isaac in case you get home so
we're gonna go grocery shopping and then
I'll show you the madness at the local
grocery store so yesterday we filmed JK
news and heading over to the office the
streets were like practically empty it
was really eerie at 8 o'clock in the
morning
there was like almost no one in the
streets or on the freeway where I'm like
this is really weird this is like kind
of semi apocalyptic feeling but I don't
know I'm trying not to overreact like
the rest of the world is just that I
have a very serious fear of staying at
home with no food because you guys saw
we'd barely have anything I've been
texting the girls in the group chat they
were like yeah there's nothing in the
grocery stores there's so many empty
shelves they also recommended that I
just go to the grocery store now and not
even wait for KC because they were like
the longer you wait the more things are
gonna be sold out so I don't know I'm
kind of thinking maybe I should just
leave right now
yeah that's that's the state of today
today what day is it let me tell you the
date today is March 13th Friday March
13th oh it's Friday the 13th
oh that's even more creepy I don't know
I don't know I just creeped me out a
little bit wish me luck
all right this is the cart currently
there's a lot of canned foods like I
said we have we're shopping for regular
shopping and we're just prepping a
little bit cuz we don't know look Isaac
and Casey join me regular shopping but
then we get here there was all like
like okay over here we can even talk it
through
yeah they there was like no this is all
we could get like everything was either
everything less was either wheat or
gluten free so it's kind of funny at
this point because then you actually get
to see people's preferences yeah no one
wants to be healthy yeah that's so funny
but how is school baby who's good is
everyone chillin at school or is there
like a sense of panic at all kind of
clear desktop and put everything in our
backpack
everybody's saying that they might shut
down the school what that's nuts
people are coming in in our school to
like clean everything yeah disinfect to
disinfect everything so we might go to
school Monday
but these possibility just stay home I
don't know we're just we're trying to do
what we can and it's crazy that we have
to stock up now when tomorrow we're
supposed to be getting our fridge so we
have to move a lot of thing I don't know
this is why owner gee we should save the
shopping for Sunday and then the longer
we wait the less stuff that there is to
pick so I'm not trying to wait we should
get some potatoes I don't know it was
weird cuz coming here you could see the
whole parking lot is all packed and
there are no carts like luckily we were
able to find a car and then just to add
on top of everything else it's gloomy
and it's been raining so even the
weather is making us feel like it's a
good scare your in Saturday's all of a
sudden yeah Sonny no Sonny it would be a
lot better but it's like even the whole
like weather like the planets like yeah
you guys should not be in a cheery mood
right now all of the lanes are open
that's how you know it's nuts I feel
guilty I feel guilty because I don't
want to see I don't want to take more
than what we need because there's other
people that meet like you know the
elderly need it more than we do but it's
just the fact the simple fact that we
don't have any food period
just kind of threes all we have to stock
up that's my card
[Music]
all right this is our score for the
first the first load right Isaac I know
we're still gonna go to the Asian market
next and see what we can suck up because
we have zero rice and we definitely need
rice so see if we could get some rice
because all the rice we have in the
world right now is this much it's very
very little we got this baby right the
Asian market now but yes
heck yeah people don't like the rice
that we get let's go that's good for us
let's go
yeah sorry stocking up at least getting
to it should be enough hopefully I don't
know I hope we're trying to find ramen
but only have a spicy stuff is left
people like the spicy yeah especially
with the toilet paper shortage yeah not
a good idea alright we're back from the
Asian market and it's kind of cool cuz
they still had some of the American
stuff so we were able to just get a
little bit more pasta yeah orange
chicken for today yeah
and then you know it's crazy they limit
the rice one per family isn't that crazy
it's like but that's the part that I had
never encountered before where it's like
oh limit one or whatever I'm glad they
did that because people shouldn't be
stocking up like crazy like removing it
from other people kind of stuff that's
all I was like maybe two bags but even
then I was kind of like I don't I don't
know do we really need that much
probably not everything else that we
have we're like that we've been able to
stock up on I'm like well I think this
is not going way out of our comfort zone
considering the fact that we literally
have nothing in the house but I was
trying to be very mindful to like not
over by and like panic buying stuff I
think we did pretty good like I mean I
don't know I think we did all right are
they really good
don't nobody know what we're really
panicking about honestly well it's that
the world really shutting down another
thing too was on our way home back home
from H Mart I got an email saying that
Isaac school will be closed until April
6 so it's a whole three weeks of him
being at home with us
whoa whoa you didn't actually hit it
are you angry yeah why you don't want to
spend time with us just kidding I don't
blame you I'd rather spend time with
friends too then parents your whole
school come over and then just be like
pointless as to why they're you guys
closed your school because everyone will
be here no just kidding
oh yeah let's put all this stuff away
now that we're home and now that we're
calm and now that we're stocked up and
then we can work on putting stuff away
for the house like I really want to
mount the TV right over there which I
got to stuff I know me too
and then I have to do this for the
pantry so to put all this stuff away we
got yeah I know maybe we could take a
little break huh oh nevermind you're
motivating yourself because I'm like
maybe we could take a little break if
you are very rich I don't like just
seeing how gloomy it all is I'm just
like that and then I'll probably do so
we're still commuting to Isaac school so
we're driving like I can hour each
morning with traffic in fact yeah 20
minutes yeah exactly
we're waking up super early not
necessary going to see early either
early enough and then being on the road
and then with all the stresses of all
the stuff that's happening the world
like kind of not together yes yes
stressful it really inspired I'm really
really stressed Dave I get here we go
yeah today's almost finished yes
no you should have done what we should
just stay at the house the old house
I guess cuz then it was lustrous you're
right eliminating that one factor would
be nice because that's a huge stress
factor but then again at the same time
not really because you remember how
stressed we were continuing to live
there with really bad internet with the
with the lights going on and off like
the only electric grid in that city was
really bad where our power would keep
going off it's not good yeah and then
our neighbors
oh it was so loud and like street racers
later like beat up in that parking lot
and skateboarders yeah skateboarders and
people are doing doughnuts in the
parking lot now it was bad I like tents
like midnight yeah sometimes even like
at 2:00 a.m. together
yeah I'm glad I'm here I mean yes it is
really stressful but it's better here
than been there yeah precision work
they're like maybe if I do this you'll
be less likely to make a mistake
what are mistakes that you're trying to
avoid this time around being crooked
[Laughter]
that's like the one the only thing to
really kind of like not do
[Music]
remember the times were used to play
minecraft a lot yeah and we literally
built our own house this this house this
this layout and and then who was in
charge of setting up the the kitchen and
pantry and who was doing it in real life
now we got to like do it virtually now
we're doing it in reality I know yeah
and then like me and Isaac were saying
earlier like like you know how minecraft
is just there's a survival mode yeah now
we're in survival mode in real life I
like the pattern you picked up it makes
the pantry look really like has a lot of
character yeah which you know a lot of
people's pantries they look kind of like
whatever you know the funnest thing
you've gotten I'm gonna show them the
new cat thing okay that's a fun piece
yeah you really need to buy a whole
bunch of those clear like containers or
boxes or whatever like you know like the
drawer thingies oh yeah yeah and they'll
be really organized and I really want to
get a whole bunch of little jars and we
already have a wave Lemaitre and I
bought a lot of labels so eventually
it's gonna be even more beautiful and
organized I like this though this makes
me really this makes me want to cook
really really bad now yeah I've never
seen my spine ever seen my spices so
organized and like before I've always
have to like dig through and like grab a
bottle yet what does this one say I
don't know paint grab another always
this one say oh no no no and my oh
that's the one yeah
and like this I can see everything I not
doing very much over here but I wash
this thing which now bill will become
the rice holder we want it to look more
more what do you call this rustic we
want to put everything in specific jars
to make it look better and not so like
branded yeah organized all right here's
the finished pantry look at this beauty
well it's gonna be a lot better once I
get those clear containers I was talking
about and then it will be a lot more
organized but this is what we got so far
I'm pretty happy with it
[Music]